all right well good afternoon everyone I
think we'll go ahead and get started
with the webinar today on the screen you
can see a few details about what we're
going to be doing today this is an
update to a webinar that we did a few
weeks ago about API keys for getting
better data from the utilities and from
a direct and if there are questions that
we don't get to answer when I'm done
talking
at the end we'll be certain to post
answers to those a few days after the
webinar is over also and the materials
the PowerPoint that I'm going to be
showing along with a PDF version of the
PowerPoint or available at the go
usa.gov link right here that you can
access anytime
all right so without further ado we'll
go ahead and get started here at the
webinar today again this is an update so
this kind of part 2 of a discussion that
we started a few weeks ago actually on
November 8th about API keys for the
e-utilities this is our main API to the
entre databases and also edirect which
is a unix command line version of these
api's also is affected by these new keys
so this is essentially an example of
community involvement with webinars
which is exciting we had a lot of
questions from our November 8th webinar
and we learned a lot of different things
from those questions one is that there's
a lot of community interest which is
great it's great to hear people paying
attention to this and also that there
were a number of interesting side topics
to the API keys that we hadn't included
in the November 8th webinar that people
were interested in and so we've included
some of that today and also it was clear
to us that we needed to be more clear
about a few aspects of how these keys
are going to work in particular so I'm
going to be providing you with more
details today about exactly how they
work and some scenarios that might occur
out there when you're beginning to set
these up and watch some likely
consequences of the various scenarios
are
so and I probably won't cover everything
that might be and everyone's heads out
there so again if you do have questions
please let us know and we're happy to
answer those as we can so for any of you
who were not at the earlier webinar on
the 8th I'm going to go through a few
basic things just to review what's going
on quick review of what the e-utilities
are so that we know exactly what the
api's are that are being affected by
this a little bit about what the keys
are and then I'm going to expand the
discussion about what happens without a
key and what happens with a key and also
just for fun what happens when you mix
and you have both a key and not a key
and what kinds of things could happen in
those situations and then finally to
finish up how do you get a key how do
you use it and when does all of this
take the fact and when do I have to have
stuff done by so what we're doing is
we're introducing new API keys for the
e-utilities api and these keys are
fairly popular with a lot of other API
providers we're now getting into the
business of providing these as a way of
registering activity and also trying to
manage the activity of these API is our
API SR are free and open to the public
but with absolutely no regulation on how
they're used they are vulnerable to
attacks and service problems because of
those kinds of high usage Peaks so we
want to make it a fair use resource for
everyone and so on May first of 2018 we
will begin limiting access to the
e-utilities on the basis of an IP
address to a rate of no more than three
requests per second well I'm much more
to say about what that means in a few
slides more that's for IP so one of the
key things to take away is that if you
don't have a key what we're going to do
is look at your IP address if you do
have a key then you get a higher rate
limit ten requests per second by default
regardless of what IP you're using right
so we only look at the key if the key is
present all right so then the IP doesn't
matter the traffic could be coming from
multiple IPS and
find it's the same key it's the same
regulation ten requests per second by
default we can negotiate with you higher
rate limits than 10 if you would like
and if you can demonstrate a need and so
if you are in that situation then you
know that you're going to be needing
more than ten requests per second then
please contact us and I'll have more
information about how to do that at the
end of the webinar so that's some basics
what are the e-utilities so the
important part of this slide is I'm sure
many of you are familiar with the
e-utilities but it's really good to talk
about scope these keys are only being
applied to the classic utilities East
search a summary fetch link post also
East fell eg query those guys not to the
blast API not to any of other variation
services API is there any of the other
API is that NCBI offers only to these
utilities for this point in time now
that might change as this matures but
for now the only thing that we're really
talking about are the classic EU Atilla
T's for entre and the key itself is just
a string it's a unique string that you
can acquire and it identifies you to our
servers and it should be included every
time you make an API request and so it's
simply a URL parameter and I'll go
through that in a few minutes also but
it just gets included in every request
and it's attached to an NCBI account so
many of you may be familiar with my NCBI
accounts as they were once called or
other submission accounts at NCBI
they're all the same they're all an NCBI
account if you have an account you can
create a key today and it will be
attached to that account if you don't
have an account it's very easy to make
one and then you can create a key and it
will be attached to that account so
let's talk a little bit about what
happens what will happen in May if you
don't have a key all right you just go
on the way that you have been going so
while we will be doing is we will be
looking at the IP addresses all right
from whence the requests come all right
so I have over here on the left three
users all at different IP addresses so
what's going to happen to them on May
1st when the switch gets thrown in the
API keys are now in effect well this guy
here is coming in at about two requests
per second without a key no problems
alright he won't notice anything all
right as long as he doesn't go above
that no problems this person is coming
through from a different IP at five
requests per second what will happen is
they will be received error messages and
I'll show you an example of what those
error messages look like but those
requests will for all intents and
purposes fail right and that person will
need to reduce the rate below three per
second to resume activity and one thing
to be clear this is not a block in the
sense that in CBI sometimes blocks IPS
because of abuse and then they have to
be unblocked this is a every second
we're looking and checking what the rate
is so all you have to do is reduce the
rate and then you'll have access again
so it's a dynamic rate control so but if
you're above that three per second limit
you're going to essentially be
temporarily blocked and receiving error
messages so that's the unfortunate fate
of this person in the middle person on
the bottom about averaging one and a
half requests per second no problem
alright so continue on as they have been
going now let's talk about a slightly
different scenario let's talk about two
users who are sharing the same IP they
might be behind a firewall they might be
using the same kind of software
interface whatever it is they're coming
from the same ip right so the guy that
was doing five requests per second is
still out of luck right we see that IP
address he's not getting through however
and this is important the first user who
is now at the same IP as the second guy
is also getting blocked because that IP
is exceeding the limit in fact it's
exceeding it by more now because that IP
is not giving us seven requests per
second alright so both users are blocked
so while this person was not actually
exceeding the limit on his or her own
they get blocked because someone else is
using the same IP and they're exceeding
the limit
or I could have made a lot of slides
here I'm trying to keep it brief then
let's say there are several people and
they're all doing one request per second
and they're all doing at the same time
if there's five of them that's five
requests per second they all get blocked
right so it's an IP address so however
that works for you the IP address is the
thing that we're looking at if a key is
not present here's an IP address down
here it's a only one person using this
IP address they're still doing
one-and-a-half requests per second no
problem the IP address has not exceeded
the rate so that's the important thing
to remember it really is about IP
addresses come May first that's how
we're looking now how do you measure the
rates right there's been several
questions about this so what I've done
here is put a little time bar up here at
the top and each one of these weird low
H like things is a request request start
execution and request stop when the data
is delivered back to you these are
actually the execution times you can
imagine on our servers I'm not including
Internet traffic and all of that but
this is just what NCBI servers would see
your request comes in at a particular
time it executes for a particular time
and then it finishes so the rates that
we're looking at are the rates at which
that requests are received by our
servers there are timestamp of the
request start so the left part of these
little figures right it doesn't matter
how long the request takes to execute
it's only when we see the initial
request so let's take this first case
this could be a single IP address or it
could be a key it's an activity stream
that we're seeing all right on the
servers there is no case where three
more than three of these requests starts
occur in the same second that's what's
important right and it is a moving
window it's not that we count every
second but it's a moving second window
so if you look at the second one there's
going to be a problem here because
there's one two three four requests that
begin in that second window right so
that's going to throw the error right
that's when the rates exceeded all right
now just to prove another part of the
point
here here's a case where the requests
are taking a long time these requests
are only taking a few hundred
milliseconds these requests might be
taking over a second and certainly in
the case of fetch or link requests can
take many seconds so what happens in
that case this is all fine this person
will not receive any errors because
there is no case when the requests start
more than three per second it is
absolutely true that during this period
there are four concurrent requests that
our servers are executing from that same
IP address or the same key that's not
what we're counting we're not counting
simultaneous execution we're simply
looking at the request start times so
you can have as many of these things
going at the same time as you want as
long as you don't start requests more
than three times a second so hope that's
clear but that's what we're doing in
terms of the rates alright now that we
understand a little bit what's happening
if you don't have a key and how we
calculate the rates what happens if you
have a key okay so I got my key it's all
very exciting and now I'm going to start
using it so after May first what would
we expect to happen here's the first guy
it's an IP address he's doing now I can
do up to ten so I'm doing seven requests
per second here's my key and notice it's
API underscore key is the parameter that
we use that's what you put in your
utility request in the URL and there is
my little key yours will be
significantly longer than that but just
to fit it on the slide here's a little
key that's completely great right this
person can go on as much as they want at
seven requests per second here's this
guy he okay I'm really gonna go after it
fifteen requests per second well we told
you that ten requests per second is the
limit so you get error messages just
like someone without a key over three
per second is going to get error
messages the same error messages all
right you're temporarily blocked what
this person would need to do with their
request is calm that down a bit below
ten right and then they'll have access
restored again immediately right here's
the other guy okay he's doing four
requests per second that's great he has
his own key all
all hunky-dory right now let's think
about some other situations what if
these people share the same IP and again
that was what we were talking about
before these two users are behind the
same firewall they're at the same
company whatever it might be they're
coming to NCBI from the same IP it
doesn't matter anymore now right because
they have separate keys the only thing
that we're looking at now is the key so
this key has seven requests per second
totally fine he goes through this key
has 15 that's exceeds the rate it gets
blocked so previously while people from
the same ip would have gotten blocked by
one person at that IP exceeding the rate
or if they all collectively were
exceeding the rate if everybody has a
key you're all independent right so now
you're just looking at the individual
keys it doesn't matter how many keys are
there behind the same ip it's key by key
and again this guy down here isn't
affected by all of this he still just
has one IP he has his key he's under 10
per second he's good all right let's
think about another case let's think
about a case where someone is sharing a
key all right so now all the IPS are
different but the first two cases are
sharing the same key maybe you decided
to have different users of your software
share the same key or you've shared the
key with the colleague now what happens
well this guy thinks he's great right
because I'm just doing 7 per second it's
beneath 10 everything's great but down
the hall or across the wherever there's
someone else using the same key at 15 so
they both get blocked right because it's
just the key the key is seen 22 requests
per second it's way over 10 everything
with that key is going to get blocked
until that rate gets below 10 so that's
the key thing to remember once you have
keys if you share them you become
vulnerable for any person who has the
key to block everybody with the key and
this guy down here is still fine right
he has his own key he's crew
at four per second no problem let's
think of another scenario let's think of
a big organization everybody has the
same IP right we're all behind the same
firewall we're all behind the same
Gateway whatever it might be two of us
have a key this guy doesn't have a key
all right so what's happening well I
have my own key you just told me it'd be
better if we all had an independent key
right great so I have my own key I'm
cruising in at 7:00 per second you're
great
no problem right because your key is
unique no one else is using it you're
beneath ten requests per second this guy
though has a key and he's still
insisting at 15 requests per second not
gonna work he gets blocked right he gets
our messages because his key is
generating more than ten requests per
second regardless of the IP doesn't
matter what the IP is however here's
this guy some guy down the hall on
different floors maybe over in Europe
somewhere didn't get the message didn't
get the memo about the API keys isn't
using one right yes no key what happens
if it has no key we look at the IP
address right look at the IP address and
say what's coming from that IP address
well goodness there's 24 requests per
second coming from this IP address from
all three of these people bought right
it exceeds three requests per second so
this is a problem right so if you have
some people sharing an IP address some
of them don't have keys that people
don't have keys are going to be affected
by the people who do have keys and are
at a higher rate right so that's
something to be aware of for cases where
we're you're sharing an IP address how
would this not have been as bad well if
this guy had a different IP this would
all be solved right because then we
would look at his IP or her IP and we
would only be seen two requests per
second from that IP these people's
activity would not be on the same IP all
right so you wouldn't notice it that
only is the case if you don't have a key
so again to review these are the
principles any IP that post more than
three requests per second
will receive errors if a key is not
present so the key is not present we
look at the IP address right and three
is the maximum if a key is present we
ignore the IP address and look at any
activity that's coming from that key so
some people ask well let's say that I
have my laptop at home and my computer
at work and my computer at my
consultants office and who knows what
got all different things I'm using the
same key everywhere
well all of those activity streams some
from our point of view into one activity
stream because it's all from the same
key so the sum of all that activity is
more than 10 that's problem you're going
to get an error message so when you're
thinking about your actual activity you
want to think about these principles and
think about how many keys are you going
to share if you're gonna share them at
all because it's risky right if you
share keys anyone that goes above the
limit is going to cause problems for
everybody with the key so you want to
think about what those limits are and
what they might be
and again if 10 is not going to work for
you we understand that and we're
perfectly happy to negotiate a higher
rate if you need that we just need to
have you work with us to demonstrate why
you need it and then we can help you get
to a rate that will work for you and
work for us all right
so a few more details that came out of
some of the questions I'm just going to
cover these really quickly there may be
many more that you're curious about this
is the error message effectively it's
going to look like this we are thinking
about providing a service in the near
future where you can actually send a
request and you'll get the error message
it's not live yet but we're considering
doing something like that because we
understand that many people would like
to just have their software get it
directly and then have to parse it in
some way or detect it in some way that
this is essentially what it will look
like and if the request produces an
error it's like a bounce
all right the request does not execute
all right so you would need to resubmit
the request it's not a delay it's not a
time of execution penalty at this point
it just bounces off so it's dead so you
will need to resubmit any request that
receives an error message at least you
get the error message
back so you know which requests received
the air message any requests that didn't
receive the error message is fine but
once they get the error then you're
going to need to resubmit few questions
about encryption so all of the utility
traffic now should be coming over HTTP
and that of course encrypts all of the
parameters in the URL including the key
but if you're passing that key around
any other way before you actually get it
into the request object then that
encryption is up to you
the developer all right so all we're
saying is that HTTP will take care of
the actual communication request and the
encryption of that request that anything
else you're doing manipulating the key
before or after the requests that's up
to you in terms of how you want to think
about security and encryption and again
just to make the point again the only
way to prevent multiple people from
interfering with one another is for them
all to have their own key that's the
ideal everybody has their own key it's
their own fault all right if they go
over the limit once you start sharing
and I'm not saying you shouldn't share
there might be reasonable cases where
sure is reasonable but just be aware
that you could have people surprised and
getting affected by other users that
there have no idea about all right so we
talked about this last time but just in
case you haven't heard all you have to
do to get a key is get an NCBI account
and you can find the account log in up
here on the upper right of any NCBI page
it's very easy create an account and
then you'll find on the main page of
your account there's an API key
management section just click the button
click the button you get the key copy it
use it that's it all right one keeper
NCBI account all right so one key
Principia account if you need additional
keys you're going to need to make
additional NCBI accounts to have those
keys and again I've alluded to this but
all you do to use the key is simply
place the value assign it to this
parameter API underscore key in any
utility request and if you're using
either
even easier there's an environmental
environmental variable NCBI underscore
API underscore key you just set that
environmental variable to your key and
you're done right you can do that in a
config file or just you know as a direct
man however you want to do that but once
the environmental variable is set
edirect will look at that and then
provide the key to all the requests
automatically for you and again question
like this if you don't like your key
anymore you think it got stolen you're
concerned about the key you can always
get rid of it
go back to your mountains to be out
you're in CBI account you know create a
key and then the old one will
immediately be defunct all right and the
new one won't be activated immediately
so you know again have one keeper
account so you can replaced at any time
but just remember when you replace it it
immediately is dead and will not work
anymore all right so all happens on May
1st all right if next year so we would
encourage you to go ahead and get a key
start playing with it it's not going to
do anything right there is no
restrictions in effect currently but we
still would encourage you to get a key
and start thinking about how you want to
strategize about if you're gonna share
it you're gonna provide it to users
you're gonna ask users to create their
own keys whatever kind of strategy you
want to think about good to start
thinking about that now we would also
encourage you as developers you are
developers to continue using the tool
and email parameters because they're
very helpful the tool really should be
the value the value of that parameters
really should be the name of the
software package and you can potentially
have many many keys associated with that
one tool value so the key does not
necessarily help us understand what the
software package is and that can really
help us help you in terms of monitoring
activity you're getting back to you
about concerns with what's going on with
the activity if someone's abusing your
tool we can help you understand how
that's happening but we can't do that
just from the key we'd need the tool
value to really help you ideally and the
email is really helpful to be a
developer contact because if you're
distributing something
the end users are going to have keys but
we don't need their email addresses we
need your email address as a developer
as to who to talk to about how to solve
the problem with the software so we
continue to encourage you to provide us
with those contacts so that we can
really help you in the case there are
issues so the tool and email parameters
not required have nothing to do with the
keys but we would encourage you to
continue using them just to allow us to
have that direct contact with you now
one thing that I want to announce in
early 2018 we will be conducting a few
test periods when the API Keys turn on
so this has been a request from several
people they'd like to test them they'd
like to test their code with the keys
working so we don't have any dates or
times planned yet but we will not be
doing these until at the earliest
January of 2018 but very likely for
maybe a few hours on a particular day we
will turn them on and then you can have
at it and test your code and see if the
keys are working as you would expect
them to it we'd obviously be very
interested in how that works out for you
because it's a test for us too so that's
going to be happening at least a few
times all right throughout early 2018
well before the May 1st date and we will
be publicizing those on our on our blog
on our social media and on utilities
utilities announced down here that's a
great mail list really encourage any of
you who want to keep abreast of those
things to subscribe to utilities
announced and will very likely be doing
more webinars and more posts about this
as that they approaches and if you have
additional questions about that please
let us know and again write to us at
info at NCBI if you have any questions
after this webinar I think at this point
I'm going to be quiet and see if we have
questions there were a couple of
questions during the talk
the main they're really sort of a
circulate around this idea of everybody
needs to get their own key his or her
own key so I just want to emphasize that
that if you're distributing software you
should have some mechanism for your end
user to enter the key that they obtain
themselves from NCBI
and someone suggested that we put that
in the documentation and I think we
should do that so if it's not in the
utilities documentation I think we
should add that and so right now that's
that's it I think you've answered the
other question that this person had
which was about the IP versus what
happens when you have a key cuz I think
you covered that fairly thoroughly so
please if you have any other additional
questions we'll stay open for a couple
more minutes and we can answer them okay
I see another question Eric does this
change the overnight window for large
jobs so the answer to that is
essentially no effect what we have been
doing in the past when we have not had
keys and it's been more unregulated is
we've encouraged people if you have
large jobs to do those in the overnight
hours or on the weekend simply because
you're likely to get better response
times and you're likely not to interfere
with other people as much when you're
doing that I think that advice would
still hold going forward what we would
also anticipate is that once the keys go
live we should have less cases of high
volume traffic that is really impeding
progress for the users because the keys
will be limiting that so it very like
will not be as much of a problem as to
win you actually submit your job because
the keys are active 24/7 doesn't matter
when the requests come in they're going
to be limited the same way regardless of
the time but it's it's likely just the
way the traffic patterns work you'll
still probably get better service to a
certain extent more freedom on the
server's overnight and on the weekends
so there's no reason for you to change
that behavior so a couple more questions
will there be a way for us to obtain
multiple keys and provide them to our
users so it's a good question and at
this point we don't have a mechanism in
place for a particular automatic call to
generate multiple keys it's something
that we've noted from one or two people
and it's on the
of consideration but for right now the
only way to get a key is to establish an
NCBI account and then get the key that
way so if we have an update on that
we'll certainly let you know it has been
something that a few people have asked
for but at the moment there's no
automatic way to get a key another one
any suggestions for server based
software for our software there isn't a
good user to use for a key I suppose for
that it might be interesting to hear
more about your specific situation
in that in that case there there have
been I mean one thing I guess I should
say is it's important just to know what
the what your frequency of load is and
to have some understanding of that it
may be that in many cases the three per
second-- limit is going to be a rare
thing for you to hit from a particular
IP because if you're I mean I don't know
how distributed your packages so or how
many IPs we would be seen from the
activity from your package if it's
really just one IP then your need to be
much more concerned about the rate
obviously if it's a distributed thing
and you know you have a thousands of
users all over the place then each user
would have to exceed that three per
second rate on their own all right to
have an effect at all so that's one
question you may not need the keys in
that sense otherwise it's something
where you know each of the individual
distributed packages would need to have
their own key in some way to be able to
get over the limits or to get or to have
the limit be higher I'm not sure I'm
answering your question well but if I'm
not I'd be happy to follow up with you
after this with some more particulars
about your situation so another question
is about do we have any documentation on
how to put the key in the code I think
the answer to that is it simply goes in
the URL when you're in whatever way
you're passing the URL to us right yeah
thanks for the question I would we
haven't put anything in the
documentation specifically about this we
and put some guidance in but as Peter
was saying the the thing that's that's
necessary is for the key to go into the
URL right or the post whatever whatever
object you're creating to send the HTTP
request it just needs to go in there how
it goes in there we don't care right
there's any number of ways it can be put
in there so it's it's very like what
edirect us and this is one
straightforward way of doing it is the
key gets stored in some kind of
configuration entity so it's an
environmental variable it could be a
configuration file it could be any other
thing that's stored in the software as a
preference on the disk as a config
whatever it might be key is stored
somewhere software reads it and puts it
in all the requests that's probably
that's one approach I'm sure there are
many approaches that I will not think
about or think of many many creative
people out there in terms of how you
deal with keys but effectively there's
any any way you want to do it is fine
with us as long as the key gets into the
HTTP request so we very well may be
updating the documentation to add some
examples of how to do that but I think
that's all I could really say right now
okay Eric do you think it would be a
good idea for the person who asked about
the server software should they write to
you yes absolutely they could write to
me yeah so I'm not sure it's in my
slides
it's sa Y ers at NCBI NLM not nih gov
which is the same suffix you see down
here you can also just write to info and
it'll get to me or get to someone who
can answer your question no problem yes
we'd love to talk to you about that
I mean we're absolutely confident that
there's lots of situations we haven't
thought about as much as we need to so
if you do have a situation that we're
not covering please let us know because
I'm sure there are other people in your
situation too ok thanks Eric and thanks
everybody for coming today and I think
we're going to end the webinar at this
point